what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports you know I love a
good heel turn as much as the next man
but if you're a pro counter-strike
player you're at a premier tournament
and there's a bucket of cash on the line
killing your own teammates probably not
the best strat liquid
trying to take the match over the line
at what is that what just happened Elise
just killed two his teammates
what is this is it a Trojan horse that
has to be paid off how is that even
possible and yet it happens whether it's
just a player who's so hot he's
headshotting everything in sight or just
bad communication we compiled the
ultimate list of csgo team kill fails
now before we get into it guys I need
you to be a team player kill that
subscribe button and a promise next
round I'll copy up for you episode of a
TV season you can't just tell your
teammates like this sausage race once
phrase 2 inches gone down great ground
from MBK please that was pissed
barbecuing sharks at the end of the
round really like they were trying to
push down he wanted to kind of refire do
you happy made the second one and unreal
absolutely unreal that that happened how
do you feel you are playing so far in
this tournament we saw some amazing
rounds including the 4k from you in the
first half yeah feeling good actually I
start off the piste around with a C
hey it's good there's been killing each
other
he takes that me throw Dredd you're
supposed to kill phase I mean it's
definitely a contribution of sorts but
maybe not they were looking forward to
versus poor and fun appears to be afk or
he really likes blue doors how about
doing what he needs to do to get the
bomb down
get out of here spawn just five the
plots all the powers gone now but the
sponges is having issues maybe is having
issues is there a storm maybe there's
like an alien ship maybe they're getting
invaded by ideas going for any of those
maybe liquid just didn't even eat done
maybe Peter to decide oh no is going on
oh no God what's happening device and I
think his teammates internal rivalry
sacrifice to the Viking gods in Dupree
was catching up to him on the scoreboard
that's one way to make sure you finish
on top I've seen this in the TV show
yeah it's true
again just I think they call it going
for suck is when you when you reach that
level sending your maid off to Valhalla
[Laughter]
can't be real that is don't do that ever
again
oh no device taking down slave mutating
the Danish ranked device trying to make
up for his earlier transgression it's
the blood sacrifice but gives them that
extra power clearly cuz just gets a
triple kill in that round slave
they have no idea where a second player
looking to play make a championship play
here
Hobbit they don't know where he is yet
oh he's killed his teammate where's the
communication they're talking by written
mail and it did not get there fast
enough he's that around time water not
like this
he's been paid off Dozier promised him
Welsh wonder everything you wanted don't
mind what is what what is going on right
there
see you some good spirits so that is
great to see especially from your
captain when you just want your captain
in the head put a TK from Zeus
oh that's crippling I mean Zeus knows
there's fighting over a trap site no
exacto areas but he's coming through a
smoke and he just comes through you know
going for that final kill you always see
Smith's fish on this map each this is
just one of his better maps oh my
goodness Choksey does get zip Knicks but
NBK decides his life isn't worth
sticking around he'd rather watch from
the sidelines four on three l.joe kills
they sacrifice get right to get the kill
on NBK that's what it takes to win
please talk about sacrifice throw ball
throw bodies on the fire enters until it
gets extinguished
it's gonna be down to Dennis now beats
that angle just to trade and only
because forest puts up look at that boys
I'm sorry problem exists to us look like
he's scolding him as well the one who's
really hard spots where you're two
against five I mean if anything it was
at least it was a head shot I was gonna
say like whenever whenever I used to TK
I always keep a jet right and that was a
reason for that because I always did it
in in style to not get right just to
remind him of dust two moments sleep if
Lauren thinks I'll get right there
[Music]
standing on top of each other audience
hates down soon oh no that's a huge
misstep look at this Oh
does he just walk right in he actually
thinks yeah but he thought he would
ascend camasta my guardian on the green
Boyer she's been over that
[Applause]
one target
I'm sure nevertheless napkins can add
insult to injury takes him down just
rubbing his face in it as has fallen as
his taco they still need to sacrifice I
want to make a play happen but burn taco
doing the work oh whoa oh oh oh wow I'm
intrigued so this is taco when you got
the first right and then cold is like
I've saved you once dude Haitians out of
EP as they have a big advantage of that
Nate it's gonna be a team date her
didn't get the memo
taco trying to make a play or maybe
thought it was the flash that would be
hilarious
three all freed up on beatdown cheek oh
no but since game killer 12 around Henry
what is this madness that's happening
flame he's about to get busy let's see
if it works for it there's what five
because he got a teammate in there as
well we're calling these I appreciate
that
teammate well he's getting shot the but
yeah well seized yeah oh he's doing his
thing don't start this radius yeah I am
cease unfold just don't don't go near
him when he's on fire like that Ricky
says no and it's a big no at that but
cut the front what watch camera what
just happened with Cutler I there was
too much fire go crazy busy but let's
see here
[Music]
wah-wah oh that's horrible i 5-story
color i shouldn't have asked for that
replay jumps down Hail Mary get the bomb
in position mpk oh that's from Kenny
yeah can you get to kill takes down his
low HP player Kiyo's gonna get a gun off
of this which could strengthen their
economy going for it gears in the mid
this time another really kill it oh
that's unfortunate the nade already
thrown getting dropped down on his dead
potty kills two teammates teammates do
some of the damage as well but this is a
little bit precarious you'll finally get
taken down by none other than happy and
he's like you have failed you must die
or no one says no one's using teams oh
oh oh okay there's a lot of TK textual
feature about this series funny enough
yeah but meant command has been fans of
situations like that you know a little
bit too Swift yeah shooting your
teammate isn't part of the plan
significant economical impact oh my holy
but what okay
he's just a bad day for that he's got
the trigger finger he's got the itchy
trigger finger hair trigger is not safe
when your teammates are in front of you
this is not looking good for hellraisers
tell me you kept okay Plus u JW finding
his teammate as he dumps back into the
smoke thankfully it hasn't affected
things too much finally we see someone
doing and Dennis gets the better of me
and twist that support
[Music]
no I play now you stop now mitt mine
boss that on low HP spy later would've
been in the world of problems but it's
now gonna be chief raggedly that was not
part of the plan quite heavily on the
miss to his he moves into the bomb
knocks it down in the last what just
happened boy so what that this looks
very good for tiny suddenly our potato
that's the wrong player he kills his
teammate and capitalizes that to
disaster some T's will be bold to see oh
no oh dear that hates it
it's a rebate jumping straight here than
in rag dolling like a discus in a quick
quick cap wrangled errors as we seen it
sees dead body shot by his teammates
Sorry Sorry
[Applause]